okay thanks so this is joint work with
no guile or non son and ramrod and as
Tony said kind of the philosophy of this
talk is to understand the impact or the
role of interaction and information and
in economics so the the motivating story
for this talk is the so-called economic
calculation problem is one of the most
fundamental questions and economics of
how to determine an efficient allocation
of the economy's resources so the
traditional view of this question was as
a pure optimization problem in which the
central planner needs to compute a
welfare maximizing partitions of the
markets items in a way that given the
the valuation profiles of the agents in
the market so for example the Ministry
of Health would like to allocate doctors
due to hospitals and the computational
complexity of this problem was studied
for almost a hundred years interesting
on its own right in fact it's a major
open problem major problem algorithmic
game theory until this very day but what
this problem formulation was missing as
pointed out in the seminal paper of
hiking back in 45 was that the the
central planner does not have the inputs
for this problem right so the valuation
profiles are actually just described
Italy distributed among the players so
each doctor knows I'm sell individually
what's his own preference list and this
of course is not known to the central
planner so how could he ever optimize
the welfare if he doesn't know the
inputs to the problem and kind of
Hayek's philosophy or suggestion was
that indeed the real bottleneck of this
problem is not
the computational one but rather the
information theoretic one so double gin
skinny sana Noren recently proposed a
formal model for studying this Hayek's
question in philosophy in terms of round
communities communication trade-offs in
the multi-party communication complexity
model in kind of the philosophy of their
work was to try and give a
mathematically formal assertion for high
x prediction that a market-based economy
is better than the centrally planned
economy by virtue of allowing for
interaction among the markets players so
the simplest model in which this
question can be posed is that is that of
unit demand bidders or just a matching
market in this simple setup we have in a
set of n bidders each one sees his own
has his own demand set of edges so just
AM bits of information whether I'm
interested in this item or not and we
should think of em always as being
linearly or polynomial II related to em
and unit demand means just that each
player as happy as so long as he
receives any item of this set so no
differences between items this is really
the the simplest settings of
combinatorial auctions so in this set up
finding a welfare maximizing allocation
is nothing else but finding a maximum or
near optimal matching in a bipartite
graph and we'll be interested in doing
so using a limited number of interaction
rounds just a little bit more motivation
about this problem obviously so what
this paper or work is really about is is
about round vs communication trade-offs
for finding near approach near optimal
matchings in a bipartite graph clearly
this is this is a very basic problem
whose
goes much beyond the economic motivation
which was the direct motivation of this
work in the previous one and in the dnl
paper was also suggested that this this
question in particular for the bipartite
matching problem is related or at least
potentially related to other models of
computation for example to space lower
bounds in multi multi path streaming
algorithms to parallel and distributed
computation in which the quest for kind
of a deterministic low communication
parallel algorithm for distributed
distributed matching is a long-standing
open problem it was suggested that
somehow studying this problem the
communication model can even bring
computational insights into the the pure
computational problem of finding a
maximum matching in a bipartite graph
for which the best known algorithm is
the forty-year-old hopcroft carp
algorithm and improving this end to the
2.5 to anything better than that is a
huge huge question so this is as far as
philosophy and motivation so what's the
formal model used the number in hand a
multi-party communication model with a
shared blackboard so in this model each
bidder is model is as a player he
receives his own inputs which is just n
bits of information whether I have an
edge to disparate whether I'm interested
in this particular item or not the
market dynamics is modelled as Justin
around a fixed round or a bounded round
communication randomized protocol with a
shared blackboard so the way the
communication goes is as follows at each
round of communication each player is
allowed to write at most be bits on the
on the blackboard and the players speak
simultaneously that will be important
for for proof and analysis and of course
the message of each player at each round
only depends on his own private input
the content the history of the
blackboard and possibly some private and
public randoms so any questions about
the the Monaco operating no no this is
there so it's there's no so that's a
good question so there's no kind of
mechanism design here whatsoever so the
the goal is completely um it's a joint
goal of computing just informing the
central planner of the least amount of
info using a minimum communication to
inform the central planner so that he's
able to output a good solution for this
optimization covers now individual
everyone is interested in maximizing the
Society's welfare and and actually this
is almost without loss of generality but
this is a mechanism design question so
let me not get into this if you force
the players to report in some way this
is without loss of generality so by the
end of the earth round when the protocol
terminates the central planner which is
just you can think of him as the referee
he's he needs to just to compute a set
of just to output a set of pairs or just
to compute to output a matching which is
solely determined by the content of the
transcript the blackboard and we say
that a protocol PI obtains an alpha
approximation to the optimal matching
for alpha larger than 1 if the expected
side or if it's a randomized protocol
than just the expected size of the
matching of this protocol outputted by
it by the referee is at least 1 over
alpha times the optimal matching Angie
and I want to stress here I just want to
remark that we will allow the protocol
to be ear honest so it might output
disconnected pairs of bitter item pairs
and we only only account the legally
matched pairs will be interested in
lower bounds so this assumption only
makes our lower
stronger so even if the protocol is
allowed to make errors our result will
apply to this more permissive model and
so at this point that the natural
question is the following so for a fixed
bandwidth suppose we fixed the bandwidth
which is usually determined by somehow
by by nature of the protocol what is the
optimal approximation ratio of an hour
around protocol so the beam skin Sonoran
showed that using only logarithmically
many bits in each round one can obtain
an end to the one over roughly our
approximation and this bound is obtained
by the the really most natural protocol
in which each player just at each route
reports a random a random item in his
demands it which was not already taken
the intuition being is that you know
reporting a random item minimizes the
collisions which is the only bad case
for the protocol right the bad cases
where encore and I report both the same
item and then one of us has to lose so
this engineer is also considering like
lengths are augmenting paths through our
rounds is so what do you mean by yeah so
the intuition really is trying to
minimize collisions as long as we don't
collide and around then both of us will
be allocated again this is unit demand
so all we care about is is being
allocated some item and this result
implies in particular that the market
will converge to a constant I mean the
pro any protocol can obtain a constant
factor approximation using only
logarithmically many rounds in
logarithmic bandwidth so this is an
upper bound on the rate of converted the
the equilibrium kind of rate so to speak
in terms of lower bounds they proved a
lower bound only for simultaneous
verticals so any randomized protocol
that uses just one round so any
his protocol cannot obtain more than a
square root and factor approximation
even even if players are using a
slightly polynomial bandwidth so but
this is a was did the lower bound was
was known only for one round and the
natural question in this point is can we
do better using any number of fixed
round so in other areas of TCS it is
known that you know even two or four
rounds even a constant increase in
norman rounds can sometime gain
potentially a lot and where it was
pointed out in the dno paper that it was
even open whether a two-round protocol
can find an optimal matching an exact
matching whenever a constant factor
matching using even algorithmic
bandwidth so even that was what was open
we answered this at least partially
answered this problem by proving the
lower bound on any fixed number of
rounds so we show that even if players
are allowed to use a polynomial size
bandwidth in each round the
approximation factor of any our own
protocol is no better than n to the 1
over 52 door so there is a polynomial
loss for any fixed number of round it
also implies the first super super super
constant rate of convergence on on on
the market to equilibrium of course
there's still an exponential gap to the
to the to the optimal upper bound but at
least we know now that a super constant
number of rounds is required so in order
to describe the proof so the way we're
aiming for for a lower bound for a lower
bound for randomized protocol so the
first thing we need to do is define a
hard distribution the way we in which we
do this is we design a family of hard
distributions for any fixed number of
protocols and we do this recursively so
in all of our definitions all our
families will have in our bidders and mr
items where Mr and RR again polynomial e
related so the base case of the
recursive family namely for R equals
zero so for 40 communication protocols
our hard distribution is constructed as
follows so there are n 0 which is equal
to M 0 bidders so there be to the five
bidders and beaches of five items and
these again I remind you is the
bandwidth and think of it just as a
formal parameter now we will see that it
will be related to the number of bidders
and then and the set of edges is
obtained just by selecting you know the
natural discard distribution just a
random permutation it's easy to see that
if the players are not allowed to
communicate at all then the expected
number of matched edges of zero
communication protocol will be constant
just one edge right so that's easy to
show on the other hand every instance in
the support of our hard distribution
will always have a perfect matching so
the number of matched edges in the
optimal solution will always be n sub R
which is the number of bidders so this
concludes that the hard distribution for
for the base case how do we define mu
sub R plus one for any the inductive
step so our instance is constructed as
follows we will have n sub R to the four
bitter blocks which we call bi each of
one consisting of n sub R bidders so
remember n sub R is the number of
bidders from the previous distribution
so in our new distribution and sub R
plus 1 will be n sub R to the to the
fifth what about the set of items so the
set of items is constructed into to
partition into two sets we will have a
so-called a hidden item block for each
one of the
blocks so we will have an hour to the to
the fourth hidden blocks and we'll have
an extra smaller set of something like B
times an hour squared set of fooling
blocks and the name is suggestive and we
will see in a second why is it so now
what is the set of edges in this graph
so we connect each block bi to its
hidden block which is you should think
of it just as a random just hidden index
using a copy of the previous
distribution new sub R this is well
defined because each block contains and
sub R bidders and each block of items
will contain M sub R items okay so each
block of bidders is connected to its
head and block using an independent
disjoint copy of the previous
distribution and it's further connected
to each one of those B times and squared
fooling blocks that makes sense so each
each block of bidders is connected to
the hidden block using a copy of Musa
bar and to each one of those fooling box
using a copy and independent copy of the
distribution mu prime sub R what is mu
prime mu prime is just the product of
the marginals of Musa bar and this this
will be important so what is the product
of marginal u sub R has always its
projection on on any bitter of this
block right so the way it's it will be
crucial that each bitter here the edge
it's the edges of each bitter to the the
fooling block will be independent of
each other it should be kind of
intuitively understandable that
marginally for each bidder and no bidder
can distinguish between his set of edges
to the true the hidden block or to the
fooling book because marginally just by
construction a bidder will see the same
image the same distribution ok so what's
so in general what is the intuition here
the intuition is that
if all the players cannot distinguish
their hidden graph from the fooling
graph that most edge is reported in the
first round will be from the fooling
block this ball the number of items in
this portion of the input is much
smaller while those blocks will be the
only way to obtain a perfect matching so
so anyway so the intuition is that
little information will be revealed in
the first round about the true blocks
and there from there on we can continue
recursively so if this construction will
be will become hopefully more more
formal as we go on just notice that I
want to notice already here that the
fact that we chose and sub R plus want
to be polynomial in n sub are already
implies that in terms of be just
unraveling the recursive relation we get
that the number of bidders in the RS
instance or the r plus one grows EE
exponentially in in our and this is the
cause for suboptimal approximation ratio
so and we will see that this is
necessary at least for our argument in
order to ensure that indeed little
information is revealed about the true
block in each round so this is this will
be important so just some other
important properties we will use in the
proof so let me just fix a little bit of
notation so let j sub i denote the
random index of the fooling block of
each of each of each hidden a graph and
let's denote by g IJ the induced sub
graph just then do set of edges between
the block bi and the graphs TJ and
similarly by g UJ the projection of this
in this graph only on the bitter you so
it's just the set of edges from bitter
you to the graph TJ and finally just to
avoid confusion let's denote by ji ji
the hidden graph the edges of the the
true graph the hidden graph so in this
terminology the input of any bitter you
and block I is just is just the set of
induced
graphs on all the BN r squared plus 1
blocks right he's connected to one
hidden blog and to the rest of the
fooling block so again as we said in the
in the previous slide just by
construction we know that the set of it
just by observing a set of edges no
bidder can distinguish between you know
the hidden the edges of the hidden graph
in the fooling blocks because the
induced edges on the food on blocks have
the same marginal distribution on this
bitter as the hidden graph okay so that
that will be crucial and therefore the
mutual information between just by
observing his own input no bidder can
know anything about the hidden index J
and kind of two lemmas that we heavily
use in the proofer these are just two
two lines of applications of the chain
rule asserts efficient terms or
condition under which conditioning
increases or decreases information so
the first claim says that the mutual
information between two random variables
a and B can only increase if we're
conditioning on independent information
so to speak so if C provides new
information about be or if a and C are
independent conditioning on C can only
increase the information on the other
hand if a and C are conditionally
independent condition in the condition
on B then conditioning on C can only
decrease the information so in
particular we will have the following
corollary so the input of bitter you of
any bitter you the mutual information
between the input of bitter you and the
rest of the bitters inputs or the
bitters prior to you conditioning the
hidden graph is zero right because we
said that well GJ has the hidden graph
it correlates the inputs for example it
contains a perfect matching but the rest
of the edges to the fooling graphs were
chosen and dependent
so they're completely independent and
using claim to we have as a corollary
that the information that bitter use
input provides on the hidden graph is
that most is it is at least this
information conditioned on the the rest
of the bidders in other words
conditioning on the rest of the inputs
can only decrease this information this
property will be will be important so
the main theorem we prove is that for
any are we prove this inductively for
any are the expected matching size of
any are around protocol with polynomial
e small bandwidth is at most five n R to
the power 1 minus 1 over 52 dar which
implies our lower bound right the graph
any graph has a matching of size are
this will imply a n to the 1 over 5 to
the our lower bound alright so the way
we do this is by induction on our and
let me try to how much time you have so
six okay let me try to just give the
gist of it so for once and for all of us
just fix an RR plus one round protocol
so we're going to analyze everything
with respect to mew r plus 1 assuming
that the theorem is correct for you sub
R so let's fix any r plus 1 round
protocol pie with bandwidth at most be
and let's divide by M sub bi the the
message the first message of the
protocol in the first round of pie and
am sub you to be the messages of the
corresponding bitter you so I won't
really have time for this let me just
say what's going on here so it's not too
hard to show using sub additivity of
mutual information in the marginal
indistinguishability property that
individually every bit the mess
of each individual bidder on the hidden
graph condition on the hidden index is
very small it's like 1 minus the size of
the block squared this is this is not
enough because we want to show that the
total message of the entire block
provides on the hidden graph is small
and in information theory it's easy to
cook up examples where you know K bits
reveal zero information individually but
somehow all together the information is
super additive but luckily we have the
property from the previous slide and
using the fact that conditioning on the
the previous messages can only decrease
the information plus the data processing
inequality we can assert that the
information provided by the entire block
of bidders on the hidden graph is at
most the number of players in the blocks
times what each player individually
reveals all right so the conclusion is
that the entire information provided by
any block beyond on its hidden graph is
going to be much smaller than one bit
and using pinsker inequality this means
that in expectation over the first round
of communication of the protocol the
original distribution of the hidden
graph which was chosen to beam you are
is very close to the distribution
conditioned on this message so the
message doesn't reveal much and this is
this will be at most let's say square
root of of 1 over n are so in particular
this is these distributions are very
close so this suggests kind of a direct
Sun based round elimination argument
shall only mention briefly so what's the
intuition the intuition is as follows we
know that conditioning on the first
message of the protocol doesn't change
the distribution of the hidden graph by
much so what the players can do is they
can just take the r plus 1 round
protocol somehow
sample the first message of this
protocol using public randomness wasting
no communication at all and they know
that this message doesn't change their
input of the the hidden graph by much
and then they will just execute the
remaining our rounds of the protocol on
their on their input so as to produce a
large matching under the distribution
you are of their hidden graph does that
makes it so the problem with
implementing this this round elimination
argument is that unlike the two party
settings in the multi-party settings we
cannot simply project we cannot simply
execute the protocol pi which has r plus
one round because pi receives are much
lower instance scales with the number of
rounds right pi operates over a much
larger set of players much larger set of
inputs so in order to kind of project in
order to embed the distribution in order
to embed a graph according to Mew are in
the higher-dimensional r plus 1
dimensional protocol we somehow to embed
and sample the rest of the inputs to
this protocol so the players really want
to do is they want to take an instance
from you are and they somehow need to
complete this input so that it's it's a
legitimate input to the r plus 1 round
protocol and only then can they just
execute the protocol and I won't say
much about this but the main problem is
that so remember each bidder here is a
private has its own private set of edges
but we know that the edges to the
fooling blocks okay let me say this this
way they have to somehow complete the
rest of the inputs so that it's sampled
according to the distribution the
higher-dimensional distribution
conditioned on the input graph and
conditioned on the first message the
main problem which with this kind of
sampling is that somehow conditioning on
the first message of the protocol
correlates the private inputs of the
players with the
inputs of that that needs to be sampled
so I don't know if so this this problem
these type of problems occurring in a
parallel repetition and direct product
theories were conditioning on this event
it's not hard to cook up an example that
shows that the first message makin may
correlate the private inputs of the
players with these inputs in other words
if player number seven wishes to sample
these edges he needs to know the edge
the private edges of player number two
as well because hizmet the first message
might be lets say the core of these
inputs with his own private input so
somehow this conditioning really it
seems like it's impossible to bypass
this problem right remember we want to
sample these inputs with no
communication at all and so this is
generally impossible what saves the day
here is the fact that the edges do this
graph are chosen independently so what
we show is that since we chose the edges
to the fooling graphs in musa bar plus
one independently the only types of
correlation that are being created by
conditioning on the first message our
local correlations in the sense that the
the edges to the fooling blocks of any
bitter in this set only depend on the
content of mi in his own private input
the own private input of this bitter so
the way we formalize this is using some
conditional decomposition lemma and
again this is ignore the details but
what we show is that the Joint
Distribution of those fooling graphs
decomposes into the product of the
marginal so this is only the private
input of each bidder but that's just and
this here and so we prove this is the
main recursive lemma that we we proven
this this finishes the this allows for
this so I just want to say that this
lemma allows to perform the the direct
some argument that I alluded to not
using only public randomness but using a
combination of both public and private
ambulance
so let me just mention to open problems
so the obvious open problem is to close
up this this gap on the rate of
convergence so our intuition is that
this random trivial protocol should be
the right answer it's hard to imagine
something better than that but I think
it will be really surprising if if one
could show that log log n actually
naturally appears there another
direction is actually generalizing this
proof for this lower bound technique
into the more general into more general
valuation profile so in the general
combinatorial auction setting is somehow
more appealing for communication program
eunuch ation trade-offs because in the
general community oriole auction setting
describing just the valuation profile of
a player to each to the set of items
requires 22 to them bits to encode
because he has a valuation for each
subset of the items and therefore you
know in this model additional rounds
might have the potential of reducing
communication from an exponential number
of bits to a polynomial and indeed mm
skinny sanan or Noren show that if the
market is sub additive so for sub
additive bidders using our rounds can be
sufficient to obtain well Thea are times
M to the one over our approximation and
once again their lower bound is only for
simultaneous protocols so the natural
next question next step is to try and
prove lower bounds on more more
complicated valuation functions thank
you